Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde les hablamos de cultura y hoy
precisamente de música pues les
proponemos un Carrusel de las artes en
compañía de alguien que ha recorrido más
de 120 países un virtuoso considerado
uno de los mejores guitarristas del
mundo se trata del francés tivo Cobán
quien nos honra hoy con su presencia
olativo Muchísimas gracias por estar en
Carrusel de las artes Hola Es un placer
y voy bueno como todos los buenos
músicos como todos los virtuosos de la
historia de la música usted comenzó muy
temprano la música Los cinco años de la
mano de su padre que también era
guitarrista
de Cobán Cómo fueron esos inicios y cómo
se llega a ese nivel tan alto dentro de
un instrumento
la música estaba en la casa todo el
tiempo Mi padre estaba tocando de Don't
Stop y estaba pensando este momento que
todos los niños del mundo son músicos la
música estaba muy fuerte y empiezo a
tocar sin saber que es especial es como
la cuando nacidos en Francia hablamos
francés y estaban diciendo Bueno una
guitarra y habló guitarra es la misma
idea y después empiezo a tocar cuando
estaba como 12 años concurso de
guitarras y para mí está fantástico de
encontrar todo este mundo con la virtud
y la virtuoso tratar de tocar todo
perfecto como una un sportivo y este
dimensión me gusta muchísimo y tengo el
placer de engañar precios y empiezo a
tocar conciertos en diferente parte del
mundo
y me gusta muchísimo tocar en diferentes
países para agentes en Hong Kong en
Chile en Estados Unidos en Europa estaba
fantástico para mí de viajar con mi
guitarra para tocar para gentes en todo
el mundo es como un sueño usted lo decía
una carrera comenzada en el seno de su
familia con su padre luego conservatorio
Nacional de música de París muchos
concursos internacionales que ha ganado
también siempre fue un objetivo para
usted llegar a ese nivel a ese al ser el
mejor
sí te tengo este feeling de me gusta
mucho tratar de
de
progresar de progresar en todo en la
guitarra en la en la visión del mundo y
tengo este costumbre desde soy un niño
con la guitarra es muy complicado tocar
un instrumento de música
de de dejar todo tiempo energía
concentraciones es como un audífono
y me gusta mucho este este manera de ver
la vida de con pasión y españoles muy
mal después Disculpe muy bueno es muy
bueno
me gusta mucho la intensidad de de del
corazón cuando para guitarra para piano
para pintor pinturas para viajar
la fuerte de las cosas Me gusta mucho y
bueno para hacer un instrumentista tan
bueno hay que pasar horas y horas
trabajando usted comenzó a los 5 años
como yo lo decía no es una vida también
de sacrificio de mucha satisfacciones de
mucha devoción pero también de mucho
sacrificios sí mucho pero después es de
tener la la oportunidad de viajar para
encontrar el mundo es para tocar este
pequeño guitarra estaba tocando en mi
cama en en el sur de Francia de Francia
tengo como 11 12 años con el sueño de
tocar en Nueva York que en la changa y
en Río de llanero y ahora tengo Tengo
este oportunidad cuando estaba a 15 años
6 años estaba Sí muy difícil porque
estaba tocando la guitarra como seis
horas siete ocho horas cada día entonces
no tengo amigos no tengo vacaciones no
tengo placer de una vida normal
pero después el placer es fantástico de
de todo es muy fuerte y esa vida en esa
vida dedicada a la música y a la
guitarra usted da evocado o interpretado
mucho repertorio desde Bach que
escuchábamos al principio del programa
hasta repertorios más modernos ese
abanico de posibilidades como Cómo se
logra porque es verdad que pasar de lo
clásico a lo más moderno al rock al jazz
también exigente sí es más filosofía de
la música y pienso que la guitarra es el
instrumento perfecto para este manera de
pensar mi padre Déjame una guitarra
clásica cuando estaba cinco años pero
ello Cuando estaba joven estaban tocando
y la música pop Rock jazz estaba muy
fuerte en nuestra familia y después la
guitarra clásica la música clásica
estaba muy fuerte en mi vida para
aprender todo y con la dimensión de
virtuoso de la guitarra clásica y
después con este placer de viajar de
tocar en diferente perder el mundo de
encontrar gente esculturales otro
músicos otro artes pintores por ejemplo
estaba tocando tres meses antes en Costa
Rica y encuentro un pintor fantástico
que se llama Thomas Sánchez y es para mí
es este tipo de encuentra es Es como una
maravilla
momentos son también en mi música
entonces podemos escuchar un poco de
música actual de pop de jazz de música
electrónica en la guitarra clásica
tampoco me gusta mucho tocar bajo music
o música muy clásica y también la flavor
la el sabor de los viajes son muy muy
fuerte en mi música en mi vida Usted
acumula también diez álbumes grabados en
estudio desde Baja hay muchos estilos
diferentes uno en particular de música
de películas porque
me gusta invitar el público que escucho
mi guitarra hacer como
active en la activo como si con la
música de películas me gusta la idea que
aquí son temas que gente pues conocer y
la idea estaba de empezar de este tema
continuar a escribir a comportarlas como
si las gentes de las películas continúa
vivir en la vida y en es con este manera
es una invitación para el público a
soñar muy muy fuerte
Me gusta esta idea que tengo la
costumbre de tocar solo en las escenas
pero no soy solo es como muchas dúos con
las gentes en las salas somos viviendo
momentos juntos no soy un espectáculo
con cuando estaba un niño tengo la
costumbre de escuchar concierto de
música clásica y no me gusta la idea que
el público es mirando como una pintura y
no tenemos
afianzadas en la pintura lo que me gusta
en la música del pop cuando estaba un
niño estaba haciendo un concierto de
rock music y tengo la costumbre si si
estoy
movimiento fuerte el chico que toca la
batería para tocar más fuertes como una
relación
Sí y ahora me gusta tratar de vivir este
manera la música la música clásica que
toco cuando toco música de Back en
conciertos no estoy tocando para los
rentes soy tocando con las gentes y
usted nombraba hace un momento Costa
Rica y es verdad que en esa vida de
viajes y de giras por el mundo también
ha estado en América Latina que que lo
que más le ha gustado de esos países ha
estado en Costa Rica en toda
Centroamérica Panamá Guatemala chile
cuéntanos Cómo ha sido ese público Cómo
ha sido ese diálogo que usted quiere
hacer con el público sí estaba
fantástico me gusta mucho este parte del
mundo y tiene lugares fantásticos he
tocado en la antigua en Guatemala que es
una ciudad que es fantástica es el lugar
estaba Magic y también he tocado en
Panamá en El Salvador
sí diferente la la la la manera de
recibir la música es muy intensa y me
gusta muchas eso la la la manera de
escuchar es muy activa y después en
muchas calor porque quizás tenemos menos
menos pena de expresar nuestros
sentimientos es muy fuerte es como
los lugares me gusta mucho y también mi
otro grande placer es de hacer software
y en Salvador las olas son fantásticas
eh estaba un placer para mí de descubrir
este este será mi siguiente Pregunta
para terminar esta entrevista Porque
después de tanto sacrificio tanto tiempo
pasado al lado de la guitarra en la
música le queda tiempo para algún
pasatiempo Entonces el zorro
y viajar para estrofear es fantástico en
moroco o en América del Sur me voy a
tocar en Brasil la año que viene Estoy
muy
Y sí
el feeling de entrar en la agua para
surfear es fantástico porque somos
obligando todas las cosas como si la la
vida es diferente para dos horas y es
muy muy bien bueno y nosotros ahora
vamos a entrar en su mundo como si
entráramos en el agua para terminar esta
entrevista Le propongo a quienes nos
escuchan y a quienes nos ven por radio
Francia internet y trans24 de escuchar
un poquito de esa música de películas
Johan terrier para terminar esta
entrevista tibocoba Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros Disculpe
para mí español muy malo maravilloso
gracias por haber venido
[Música]